SEAN HANNITY FROM NEW YORK.
>> Sean: ALL ALL RIGHT, THAK
>> Sean: ALL ALL RIGHT, THAY
>> Sean: ALL ALL RIGHT, THAU
>> Sean: ALL ALL RIGHT, THA.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY," WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF BREAKING NEWS STORIES.
WE WILL COVER THEM ALL INCLUDING
ANOTHER INSANE ANTI-TRUMP
CONSPIRACY THEORY BY THE
COWARDLY SHIFT HIMSELF.
A HUGE DEVELOPMENT TODAY IN THE
MUELLER WITCH HUNT AND AN UPDATE
ON THE MASSIVE COLLEGE ADMISSION
SCANDAL.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE THE
"HANNITY WATCH" ON THE RADICAL
2020 DEMOCRATS I WOULD LIKE TO
BE PRESIDENT WITH AN
INVESTIGATION INTO BETO BOZO
ROBERT FRANCIS O'ROURKE IN HIS
HOME STATE OF TEXAS.
BY FIRST WE GET STARTED WITH THE
ROUND UP OF THE WORST MOMENTS
FROM THE DEMOCRATIC HOPEFULS FOR
PRESIDENT, SOMETHING THAT THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, WE KNOW THAT
THEY WILL NEVER DO.
IT IS ONLY TUESDAY, BUT THE
DOZEN THE FAR LEFT CANDIDATES
TRYING TO REPLACE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ARE GETTING OFF
TO A ROUGH START.
IT TAKE FOR EXAMPLE ELIZABETH
WARREN AND KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND,
THEY DO NOT LIKE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY SELECT TWO ORIGINAL
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
SO NOW THEY WANT TO GET RID OF
THE SUPREME COURT AS WE HAVE IT
CURRENTLY CONFIGURED.
BOTH SENATORS TOLD POLITICO THAT
THEY ARE OPEN TO INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES, AND THIS WOULD GIVE
THEM THE ABILITY TO STACK THE
COURT WITH THE FAR LEFT
ACTIVIST THEREBY LEAVING THE
THIRD COEQUAL BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT, WELL, FAIRLY
POWERLESS.
CONSTANTLY UNDER THE THUMB OF
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
THIS IS BEYOND UNETHICAL IT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
IT IS A POWER GRAB.
BUT WHAT ELSE DO WE EXPECT FROM
ELIZABETH WARREN?
SHE HAS BEEN RIGGING THE SYSTEM
FOR YEARS, GETTING AHEAD BY
LYING ABOUT HER ANCESTRY.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT COREY
SPARTACUS BOOKER, HE IS ALSO
TAKING A BRIEF STAND AGAINST THE
TAKING A BRIEF STAND AGAINST THS
TAKING A BRIEF STAND AGAINST THA
TAKING A BRIEF STAND AGAINST THY
TAKING A BRIEF STAND AGAINST THS
TAKING A BRIEF STAND AGAINST THP
TAKING A BRIEF STAND AGAINST THE
TAKING A BRIEF STAND AGAINST THC
TAKING A BRIEF STAND AGAINST THU
TAKING A BRIEF STAND AGAINST THA
TAKING A BRIEF STAND AGAINST THC
TAKING A BRIEF STAND AGAINST THH
LIST.
>> THE FORMER AG HAS TRIED TO
GIVE OUT AND EXPANDING PEOPLE IN
THE NINTH STRAIGHT TO COURT TO
GET MORE PROGRESSIVES ON THERE.
WHERE YOU ON THAT?
>> I THINK THAT WE NEED TO FIX
THIS IN COURT, THEY HAVE A
SUPREME COURT SEAT.
>> SHOULD WE KEEP IT AT NINE?
>> I THINK I WOULD LIKE TO SORT
OF A LOT OF OPTIONS AND WE
SHOULD HAVE A LIMIT PER SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES.
IT MIGHT BE ONE THING TO GET
EVERY PRESIDENT TO CHOOSE THREE.
PEOPLE HOLDING ONTO THOSE SEATS
IN WAYS THAT I DO NOT THINK IS
NECESSARILY HEALTHY.
>> Sean: YOU MAY WANT TO NOTE
THAT SPARTACUS WAS NOT
DETERMINING LIMITS FOR HIS OWN
RUN AS SENATOR  .
WHERE KAVANAUGH AND NEIL GORSUCH
PRESIDED.
THIS IS PART OF A FAR LEFT
TACTICS.
WHEN YOU CANNOT WIN AN ELECTION
BASED ON IDEAS AND POLICY AT THE
BALLOT BOX, THEY JUST GO TO
RIGGING THE SYSTEM.
THIS IS WHY ELIZABETH WARREN IS
NOW TRYING TO DISMANTLE THE VERY
WAY THAT WE EVEN ELECT A
PRESIDENT.
IT DOES NOT WORK IN HER FAVOR,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MY VIEW IS THAT THE EVERY
VOTE MATTERS.
AND THE WAY THAT WE CAN MAKE
THAT HAPPEN --
[APPLAUSE]
IS THAT WE CAN HAVE NATIONAL
VOTING, AND THAT MEANS GET RID
OF THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
AND EVERYBODY --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: SURE, LET'S LET
NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
MASSACHUSETTS, ILLINOIS, AND
CALIFORNIA DETERMINE EVERY
PRESIDENT.
YOU SEE, SHE DOES NOT WANT EVERY
VOTE TO COUNT.
IN OTHER WORDS SHE WANTS TO
IGNORE ALL OF THE STATES IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE COUNTRY.
THE RED STATES, OF COURSE.
NO MORE ELECTORAL COLLEGE,
NUMEROUS SUPREME COURT AS WE
KNOW IT, CHECKS AND BALANCES
THROWN TO THE WIND.
BUT OF COURSE IF DEMOCRATS GET
THEIR WAY, THE THIRD TRIMESTER
ABORTION INCLUDE INFANTICIDE
DURING AND AFTER BIRTH, THAT
WOULD BE PERFECTLY LEGAL AND
READILY AVAILABLE.
SADLY THEY ARE FIGHTING FOR
THAT.
IT WOULD PROTECT INFANTICIDE
ABOVE ALL ELSE.
NATURALLY THIS INCLUDES BETO
"BOZO ROBERT FRANCIS" O'ROURKE.
>> FOR OR AGAINST THIRD
TRIMESTER ABORTION?
>> THE QUESTION IS ABOUT
ABORTION AND REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS, AND MY ANSWER TO YOU IS
THAT THAT SHOULD BE A DECISION
THAT THE WOMAN MAKES ABOUT HER
OWN BODY.
THAT IS MY ANSWER.
>> Sean: FIRST WE WILL DELIVER
THE BABY, THE GOVERNOR OF THE
COMMONWEALTH SAID AND THEN WE
WILL MAKE SURE THAT THE BABY IS
COMFORTABLE.
AND THEN WE WILL LET THE MOTHER
DECIDE.
UNBELIEVABLE, AND THEY CALL
TRUMP IMMORAL AND EVERY OTHER
NAME IN THE BOOK.
AND THEY TOLD YOU THAT JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH WAS A MONSTER, BUT
EVERY DEMOCRAT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT CHEERS FOR THIS ISSUE
OF INFANTICIDE.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
NOW MEANWHILE, THEY TRY TO SHAME
CONSERVATIVES FOR WHAT?
WANTING BORDER SECURITY?
WANTING TO STOP DRUGS FROM
CROSSING THE BORDER?
CONTROLLED IMMIGRATION?
ON MONDAY SENATOR GILLIBRAND
SAID THAT THERE IS NO SUCH THING
AS AN ILLEGAL HUMAN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IMMIGRATION IS NOT A SECURITY
ISSUE, IT IS AN ECONOMIC AND A
HUMANITARIAN AND A FAMILY ISSUE.
[APPLAUSE]
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS AN
ILLEGAL HUMAN.
>> Sean: BETO WANTS TO GET RID
OF ALL BALLS ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, DELIVER AND THE ONES
OPEN BORDERS, NO WALLS, NO
CHECKS, NO NOTHING.
AND SHE WANTS TO ABOLISH
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT.
AND IS PROMISING TO PAY FOR AN
INFLUX OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
THROUGH THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
THE ONE THAT PROMISES TO TURN
AMERICA INTO A SOCIALIST UTOPIAN
AND TAKE AWAY ALL OF YOUR FEARS
AND THE GOVERNMENT WILL CONTROL
THEIR MEANS OF PRODUCTION LIKE
ENERGY AND HEALTH CARE.
AN ESTIMATED COST $94 TRILLION
IN THE PROCESS ON TEN YEARS, AND
KEEP IN MIND THAT THE ENTIRE
FEDERAL BUDGET WAS $4 TRILLION.
DEMOCRATS, THEY SAY THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THE
COST.
THEY WANT TO WORRY ABOUT THE
PLANET NOT BEING BURNED UP IN 12
YEARS.
THEY WANT GOVERNMENT RUN
HEALTH CARE, GOVERNMENT PEOPLE
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION FOR ALL.
GOVERNMENT PAY FOR VACATIONS,
FAMILY LEAVE, SPONSORED HEALTHY
FOOD, GOVERNMENT HEALTHY FOOD,
GOVERNMENT MONTHLY INCOME FOR
EVERYBODY PAID WHETHER YOU ARE
WILLING OR UNWILLING TO WORK.
AND BUILDING RENOVATION, EVERY
BUILDING IN THE COUNTRY.
EACH AND EVERY BUILDING FOR
ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
AND OF COURSE THE END OF ALL
FOSSIL FUELS AND PLANES IN TEN
YEARS, AND SENATOR GILLIBRAND
SUPPORT SITE, SWORD PUTT SO DOES
ELIZABETH WARREN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE GREEN
NEW DEAL, UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS ABOUT BUILDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
21ST CENTURY.
[APPLAUSE]
FOR A SUSTAINABLE WORLD.
>> Sean: AT THE SAME TOWN
HALL, WARREN PROPOSED OVER
$100 TRILLION IN NEW SPENDING.
$100 TRILLION.
THAT IS $94 TRILLION MORE THAN
THE ENTIRE 2018 FEDERAL BUDGET.
THE GREEN NEW DEAL IS INSANE,
AND IT WOULD GUARANTEE POVERTY
AND A DYING COUNTRY AND ECONOMY.
NEARLY EVERY 2020 DEMOCRAT
SUPPORTS IT INCLUDING SPARTACUS.
AND DESPITE SUPPORTING THE
BIGGEST SOCIALIST TAKEOVER IN
THE HISTORY OF THE EARTH,
SENATOR SPARTACUS WANTS YOU TO
KNOW THAT HE IS NOT A SOCIALIST.
WHILE, WHAT DO YOU CALL IT THEN?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I AM FOR CAPITALISM COME I AM
TIRED OF COMPANIES ENGAGING IN
SOCIALISM --
>> OKAY, I AGREE.
>> THEY OUTSOURCE --
>> THAT IS A GOOD RHETORICAL
POND.
WE HAVE PEOPLE IN THE PARTY WHO
ARE.
>> I BELIEVE IN FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES.
>> EVEN MATTHEWS IS LAUGHING.
>> NOW POKER IS A PERFECT
REPRESENTATION OF WHAT IS A
RADICAL SOCIALIST EXTREME
DEMOCRAT AND THE ENTIRE FIELD
FOR THAT MATTER IS THE FACT THAT
HIS PARTY HAS BEEN SO FAR
LEFT EVEN LIBERAL
BUSINESSPEOPLE, AND YOUR GANG
IS GAINING TRACTION FOR
PROMISING TO GIVE EVERY AMERICAN
PROMISING TO GIVE EVERY AMERICA$
PROMISING TO GIVE EVERY AMERICA,
PROMISING TO GIVE EVERY AMERICA0
PROMISING TO GIVE EVERY AMERICAE
PROMISING TO GIVE EVERY AMERICAC
PROMISING TO GIVE EVERY AMERICAH
PROMISING TO GIVE EVERY AMERICAA
PROMISING TO GIVE EVERY AMERICAD
PROMISING TO GIVE EVERY AMERICAE
PROMISING TO GIVE EVERY AMERICAY
MONTH DOUBLING THE FEDERAL
BUDGET IN THE PROCESS.
AND TONIGHT THAT FIELD, THE FAR
LEFT CANDIDATES IS GOING TO BE
EVEN MORE CROWDED, ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," WELL,
CREEPY, CRAZY, UNCLE JOE BIDEN
IS TELLING SUPPORTERS THAT HE
PLANS ON RUNNING.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THAT LATER,
BUT FIRST WE DO HAVE SOME GOOD
NEWS, OUR "NIGHT COURT"
"HANNITY WATCH" ON THE MUELLER
WITCH HUNT, LEAVING THE SPECIAL
INVESTIGATION COMING AFTER THE P
INVESTIGATION COMING AFTER THE T
INVESTIGATION COMING AFTER THE B
INVESTIGATION COMING AFTER THE L
INVESTIGATION COMING AFTER THE ,
ANDREW WEISSMANN ANNOUNCED HIS
RESIGNATION A FEW DAYS AGO.
THIS IS YET ANOTHER SIGN THAT
THE INVESTIGATION HOPEFULLY,
FINALLY IS ALMOST OVER.
AND ACCORDING TO REPORTS, MANY
REPUBLICANS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO MUELLER'S FINDINGS.
MEANWHILE DEMOCRATS NOW SEEM
VERY ANXIOUS.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION WAS, IS, AND FOREVER
WILL BE A HOAX.
AND IF MUELLER IS A DECENT,
HONEST MAN WITH REVERENCE FOR
THE LAWS AND CONSTITUTION, THE
ABSORBED COLLUSION NARRATIVE
WILL BE PUT TO REST ONCE AND FOR
ALL.
BUT WE KNOW THAT THAT IS NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN, BECAUSE THE
BIGGEST LIAR IN CONGRESS AND
LEAGUER HIMSELF, THE COWARDLY
CHEF WHO WILL NOT COME ON THIS
PROGRAM, I HAVE OFFERED HIM
FOUR HOURS, THREE HOURS OF
RADIO, ONE HOUR OF TV, AND HE
WILL NOT TAKE US UP ON THE
OFFER, HE HAS BEEN SPREADING
CONSPIRACY THEORIES ABOUT RUSSIA
AND TRUMP FOR AN ETERNITY NOW.
AND NOW THEY USE THE PLATFORM AS
THE HOUSE INTEL CHAIR IN ORDER
TO MALIGN THE PRESIDENT WITH
ENDLESS McCARTHY-ESQUE
INVESTIGATIONS.
AND RECENTLY ADAM SCHIFF TOLD
NBC NEWS THAT THE INTELLIGENCE
ESTIMATION IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE"
ESTIMATION IS IMPORTANT BECAUSET
GOES TO A PRESENT THREAT TO THE
NATIONAL SECURITY."
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT AND
ANYBODY AROUND HIM ARE
COMPROMISED BY A FOREIGN POWER.
OKAY, WELL, IS DATING
CONGRESSMAN, CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE COMMITTEE RECKLESSLY
PUSHING A CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT
A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT IS
CONTROLLING OUR COUNTRY WITHOUT
EVIDENCE, HE SHOULD BE ASHAMED
OF HIMSELF, BUT OF COURSE, HE IS
NOT.
LIKE MOST DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE
UNRELENTING HATRED 24/7 FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP OVERRULES ALL
COMMON DECENCY.
LOGIC, COMMON SENSE.